un vendredi soir dernier tf1 diffusait
un nouvel épisode de koh lanta
un numéro qui a particulièrement occupé
les confiner puisqu'avec 6,48 millions
de téléspectateurs l'émission réalise sa
meilleure audience depuis 2016 un
épisode qui qu'on se le dise pour a été
difficile pour ahmad alias le candidat
de lara sera un candidat de l'équipe des
rouges qu'il a bien décidé il ne
nominera pas un rouge pas question de se
faire influencer je connaîtrai pas faire
je ne laisserai pas de celui des noms
moussa rien ne sert d'essayer de le
convaincre
il ne changera pas d'avis qu'à ma parole
quoi ces bouges pas jusqu'à ce que comme
on a dit pas mot allah par le hockey la
rage qu'on sait jamais il ne dominera
aux on a dit je suis vraiment vraiment
désolé delphine g abbassi pardon mais
kaman ne s'inquiète pas ses ex
coéquipiers ont compris sa démarche et
de lui en veulent pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis ça
enfin juste un peu du coup ahmad v6 de
jouer le tout pour le tout en tentant
tant bien que mal de gratter d'amitié
avec jessica et claude avant la
réunification et pendant ce temps là
qu'en pense t au à qui fait son grand
retour dans le jeu tente de nourrir
toutes tailles et tenter la peau nomma
[Musique]
d'accord on lève le pied sur les
feuilles de coca un épisode plus court
que d'habitude puisque en raison du
confinement tf1 a décidé de diviser les
émissions en deux pour que le programme
puisse durer plus longtemps et ainsi
retarder le tournage de la finale alors
se tait souika date et dont carton pour
koh lanta déjà le premier truc à savoir
c'est qu'après la victoire des rouges à
l'épreuve de confort il ya denis carrier
denis l'ex de sophie costa il arrivait
il a annoncé quelque chose qui a surpris
tout le monde
il s'agit de la réunification et
hermétique usap est chaud et vous allez
on va faire une réunification si rester
dark shadows écolo réunification il a
énuméré duplication regarder ce qu'il a
dit qu'il n'allait pas et avec sophie
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les rouges pendant ce repas s'annonce
magique vous allez avoir une mission de
la plus haute importance alors
l'unification c'est maintenant
l'ambassadeur n'était pas prêt la tenue
il va falloir discuter et prendre une
décision capitale
vous allez dans chaque équipe de voir
désigner les deux ambassadeurs de
l'équipe adverse est frère wali avec
denis brogniart et l'annoncera
réunification dirait qu'ils annoncent un
contrôle surprise sortie de me fait
allez c'est parti de contrôle surpris
c'est que tu sais que ta rien v10 est il
temps restera totalement c'est quoi ces
tête rattrapent
on dirait qu'il aura diffèrent haut-var
mauvaise un truc de ouf et n'hésitez pas
si c'est ce qu'ont pensé que koh lanta
après ses records d'audience grâce enfin
grâce
on a envie d grâce entre guillemets bien
en tenue au confinement castaldi
spécialistes et les régimes
oui non oui évidemment que c'est quoi
honnêtement on est de bons ils avaient
bien dressé la barre le programme est
plutôt plutôt très très bien boutiques
et cette année là j'étais un épisode
très fort c'est la réification et on a
adoré ahmar qui s'est fait bouffer le
service son épisode ahmad oui à margaux
et ben moi peu importe et est en tous
les cas je me suis dit monsieur je me
suis régalé non mais je plaisante et
surtout c'est vrai qu'en ce moment on
est confiné on voit quoi tes beaux
décors ou à des belles nanas ou à
déborder des bo gars aux fosses pense à
assaillir c'est vrai ma volée alors à ce
que votre avis la cause de confinement
raymond morey beau et bon
lewis pc la selle c'est à cause du
confinement parce que tout comme l'a dit
benjamin monde et devant la télé il a
juste un chiffre un mec sur un twitter
qui de qui balancent des slips ya les
français là depuis une semaine il passe
quatre heures 30 devant la télé contre
3h57 ya quinze jours devant la télé dont
ça c'est évident c'est évident que les
chiffres sont bons tant mieux très bien
ben c'est normal qu'ils tiennent bien et
c'est là ces systèmes de delap de
l'offre et de la demande quoi que ouais
c'est clair est clair que l'offre et la
demande si tu as beaucoup de demande que
de l'offre apportée mamba depuis bab à
faire des codes atteint par la maladie
elle a perdu on a perdu un peu par
quartier dû cul pour chier droit c'est à
2 me coûte demandé que tu adoptes pas
forcément bas ça s'emboîte à papa dans
maman puis c'est l'économie qui repart
maintenant attendu attendu de brigil ne
fonctionne pas du tout c'était
uniquement
c'est uniquement grâce au confinement
pour répondre directement à votre
question parce que ça ne marche pas
d'ailleurs ils sont restés je me trompe
12 à ma marche pas ça nahman sais pas
c'était mignon et mardi des touquettois
ne sait pas alors des grandes deux jours
au lieu de 40 sur l'île et on voit que
c'est bâclé la réunification arrive bien
trop tôt même n'y avait pas de
confinement ça s'effondrera laurent ça y
est ça y est ça y est alors moi ça m'a
fait beaucoup rire parce que j'ai
l'impression de me retrouver comme dans
le monde politique
en fait non agricoles menées d'anfield
ils paraissent mieux aux politiques
non mais je pense que ça va tu as trouvé
ta retrouver ce même monde de requins
côte dans la politique c'est ça avec des
gommes le nail de ton équipe ont rien
donné
c'est fou quoi c'est vrai et dans la
politique c'est comme ça que c'est
vraiment un monde de requins ou vraiment
ok si frotte s'y pique
mam écrit les bêtes si ce à quoi s'est
vraiment fait gaffe quoi et je suis un
cactus quoi m'approche pas trop parce
que je suis sympa de loi mais si tu veux
pas proche fait la politique c'est
pareil quoi sur pick up
moi j'ai regardé j'ai regardé que les
enfants et celle du mode d'art gardena
et un boulot tard et à la poutre
naulleau de ta part maintenant on a
regardé que les emprunts c'est vrai ça
faisait des années qu'on n'avait pas
regardé finalement cette émission j'ai
trouvé que c'était très sympa je
comprends que ça fonctionne bien et
c'est vrai que ya un côté bon moi vous
savez j'adore denis brogniart
objectivement est vrai pour moi on va
rappeler c'est un ex je laime voilà oui
non et je me suis dit il à l'arrivée
elle a trouvé le totem
ouais plusieurs fois il ya pas mal comme
de nuit
étaient bien cachés dans le choc de deux
lits il faut tenir à la fois qui touche
le total de toutes les parties alalalala
senti cost à la gagner l'épreuve de
confort 1 je peux te dire qu'elle a pas
de notre façade sécheresse l'accumuler
new saints j'ai pris tout son sens la
plage à te dire qu avait pas besoin de
faire du feu sur la place j'ai tout fait
et dans six barres de brognard ils ont
pas mis longtemps sur la salle à la
salle éclate place à fumer c'est que
l'aaa je suis comédien a tapé mais j'ai
bientôt pétrole slip apprenez à 18 ans
étaient censés durer quatre mois avec
les cecos et chez toi qu'est ce qu'on me
propose de voir des gens augmentèrent
qui fait que toucher comme avant tu
regardes forcément enfin le train cela
le monde la france appelle la liberté
les vacances ils s'oxydent apparemment
ça lui rappelle d'autres aussi mais bon
ça sur le terrain et pas besoin mais tu
as eu raison tu étais content on est
toujours content de voir son ex voilà en
tout cas un koh-lanta qui a bien marché
ça savais tu peux te dire que ça a été
pas mal hein alors vous avez vu que ya
un coup de gueule de dénis brogniart qui
a répondu un twitter alors on va revenir
là dessus comme à chaque épisode de koh
lanta denis brogniart qui a commenté sur
twitter les comment les moments forts du
prime sauf que là il ya un internaute il
a taclé alors alors alors denis
brogniart il a tweeté alors les
ambassadeurs ils vont s'entendre et là
il ya un mec qui lui a mis arrête un peu
beauf on aurait pu s'arrêter là mais
géniale a répondu à qui parler vous avec
autant de familiarité jeune homme à deux
doigts d'être un peu vénère voilà sa
réponse est resté près 225 mille fois l
on voit denis brogniart frère quand il
s'embrouille
c'est à l'ancienne c'est à la méthode
brigades du tigre faisons un tunnel
demain à 8h au fleuret non mais sans
déconner bien à base de lait comme à
saint denis monière que des embrouilles
à base de attention dit pas en arrière
c'est par cuit quand l'aube sera venu le
crédit reculent en raison de la can sont
brouillées comme ça elle ne renie que sa
grand-mère well as raison il faut
toujours répondre de manière décalée
parce que ce que réparation le même ton
le clip il est trop constants l'aïe a
raison de ne lui avec un peu de vie
remis un peu de distance et très bien
joué et les gens adhèrent 125
voilà c'est génial tu sais vous avez
raison moi j'ai beaucoup de mal avec ça
j'ai beaucoup mal des fois quand je me
fais insulter la plupart du touch mon
premier tout excès il donne je suis dit
qu'on les studios on va non ça faut pas
faire ça c'est pas dire ça fait bien
jouer la mouche bravo à braga